à
certains d'entre eux qui ont
assez de harceler sur les
réseaux.
- Sous le couvert nuageux,
le temps est frisquet en Beauce.
Pas de quoi enflammer
les esprits. Et pourtant,
il y a quelques jours encore,
ces graffitis sont apparus :
"Tu as détruit ma famille",
écrit l'auteur à François
Legault et Christian Dubé.
"Je vais démolir les vôtres",
en faisant référence à Denis
Lortie, le tueur du Parlement,
en 1984.
SAMUEL POULIN, député CAQ de
Beauce-Sud
- "Je vais te trouver",
ou je vais te chercher."
ou t'sais : "Je t'attends."
ou : "Tu vas en manger une!"
Puis des fois, c'était même pas
des gens de la circonscription.
C'était vraiment des gens
de l'extérieur.
- Le député Samuel Poulin
a transféré des dizaines de
courriels menaçants à la Sûreté
du Québec dans les derniers
mois, sans compter tout
le reste.
- Des 300 courriels par jour,
toutes les lignes occupées.
- Même si tout paraît calme
aujourd'hui à son bureau
de comté...
- Plusieurs fois, je me suis
dit: "Pourquoi tu es venu en
politique?" Alors, je me suis
parlé beaucoup! Personnellement,
là, pour traverser ça, il faut
se parler, se "regrounder", puis
se dire : "Écoute, là, ce n'est
pas vrai que mon mandat, je vais
juste le passer là-dessus!"
- Faire du terrain le rassure
parce qu'il peut sentir le pouls
des Beaucerons. Même si tout
le monde sait où habitent
les députés de région, il ne
craint pas pour sa sécurité.
- J'ai des bons voisins!
ALEXANDRE LEDUC, député QS de
Hochelaga-Maisonneuve
- On a dû solliciter le service
de protection de la SQ à une ou
deux reprises, là, où les gens
disaient : "T'es mieux de te
cacher, on va aller te trouver."
- Le 1er mai, le député de
Québec Solidaire, Alexandre
Leduc, a demandé aux militants
opposés aux mesures sanitaires
d'aller manifester ailleurs
qu'aux abords de la clinique de
vaccination du Stade Olympique.
- Ça a attiré sur moi et sur mon
équipe d'Hochelaga-Maisonneuve
les projecteurs, avec tout
ce que ça implique de discours
haineux, de menaces.
- Il craignait même des
représailles contre sa famille.
- J'ai demandé à ma conjointe
puis à ma fille d'aller passer
la journée chez mes parents,
ailleurs, à l'extérieur
du quartier, là, à l'extérieur
de l'île, même.
SYLVAIN GAUDREAULT, député
péquiste de Jonquière
- À un moment donné,
ça vient lourd ou dur à...
à gérer, là.
- Les députés d'opposition,
comme Sylvain Gaudreault,
se font traiter de moutons.
Aucun n'y échappe. Tellement que
l'Assemblée nationale a dû
renforcer sa sécurité
et la protection autour
de nombreux élus.
- On a toujours tendance à aller
voir les commentaires.
Là, j'ai arrêté! J'ai arrêté,
parce que c'était délirant!
ENRICO CICCONE, député libéral
de Marquette
- "Toi, t'es mieux de pas
te promener dans la rue!"
- Même un dur à cuire comme
Enrico Ciccone a porté plainte
à la police. Il a dû doser
ses interventions, pour ne pas
alimenter les discours haineux
contre le gouvernement.
- Moi, je ne voulais pas faire
partie de ce jeu-là, alors
parfois je m'abstenais.
- À la veille de la rentrée
parlementaire, les députés
se raccrochent à une chose.
- La vaste majorité comprennent
qu'on n'a pas signé pour ça, là!
- Samuel Poulin pense que
la majorité des Québécois
les appuie, pour le meilleur
et pour le pire.
Ici Véronique Prince,
Radio-Canada, Q